okay that's not it ma'am the map is
inside
it's an ancient leg cipher doesn't need
a coat try my birthday the a-team did
just cross through alphabets hey
everybody this is gonna be my arrow
episode 16 video obviously is so much
stuff happened I was not expecting said
cast member to leave the show after this
I didn't think it was gonna happen till
much later but I think we all saw going
in this direction so we'll talk about
that in the big Easter eggs like Roy
wearing his hat from the comics probably
one of my favorite ones if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the DC videos flash
is still on break for a couple weeks but
I'll remind everybody about the schedule
at the end of the video so no worries
so obviously the big stuff this week was
that Roy Harper was back albeit to take
Thea off of the show like Willa Holland
has officially left arrow it sounds like
based on what the producer said that
this is like them saying goodbye forever
until she says hey you know I want to
come back for a guest spot so I don't
think that she's gonna be in the finale
this season which is good and bad for a
couple of different reasons he is a real
big part of Oliver's emotional core but
now that William has become more of a
regular on the show and he's married to
Felicity they're kind of his emotional
core so it's not quite as big of a deal
if Thea had left in a previous season
but I've always kind of been back and
forth on the character I felt like they
haven't done the best job writing her
especially in the earlier seasons like
she served her purpose the first couple
of episodes like hey Ollie I can't
believe you're back
speaking of which big Easter egg when
they said goodbye to each other for the
very first line of dialogue that they
spoke to each other in that pilot
episode that was actually kind of sad
[Music]
missed you so much you were with me the
whole time
Stephen Amell will sometimes tweet stuff
like that like if you've been watching
the show since the very first episode
watch out because we're gonna have a big
moment from the pilot in this week's
episode they did a great job when they
wrote her off the show like the reason
for Thea to actually leave the logic of
it is totally solid it also allowed them
to bring back a lot of League of
Assassins Canon that they kind of threw
out when Nyssa burned Rachel ghouls
signet ring
earlier today I just ANDed the League of
Assassins I released its forces much as
my father had released you long ago so
one of my big complaints about arrow in
the past is that they'll have like
really cool mythology that they won't be
able to use in a future season because
of character riots or IP issues or
actors leaving the show and they'll just
like toss it all in the garbage but most
of you probably understood the
relatively simple logic of the Thanatos
guild which is basically an offshoot of
a league of assassins members Thanatos
the personification of death in Greek
culture obviously they were searching
for the other Lazarus pits power over
death I was actually really excited when
they introduced those extra Lazarus pits
to because in the comics there's way
more Lazarus pits Batman even goes
around the world with Bane trying to
destroy them all at a certain point in
the comics so way back when they did the
hot tub on arrow and then they poisoned
it it was basically them saying we don't
want anybody to come back from the dead
using this so we're gonna have
characters destroy it on the TV show so
that it's not an option for them so that
you couldn't have characters during
season 5 go oh this person that is dead
can't we just throw them in the Lazarus
Pit we can bring anybody we want to back
I was a little upset that they didn't
make it green like it is in the comics
maybe they just felt like it was easier
to do it if it was a regular hot tub but
the idea is at the end of the episode
when they sort of ride off into the
distance to begin their mission to
destroy the pits is that when they come
back on the show you'll pick back up and
they'll have been doing this that whole
time which I feel like is a really smart
move as opposed to when they let Roy go
a couple seasons ago and he just went
and chilled out he wasn't doing anything
between seasons nothing exciting just
trying to be a mechanic they drop a
couple cool knowledge bombs the league
was founded in 1013 so that gives you an
idea of how old racial Ghul was before
he died they made a Hellraiser reference
isn't that the box from Hellraiser
that's called the tesseract
maybe they didn't use that word because
it was too close to Avengers infinity
war they had the big Indiana Jones
reference is it Raiders or Temple of
Doom its Raiders the stuff with the
sister-wives was a lot of fun too Nyssa
has some of the best jokes I will remain
here sister wife husband you can't keep
calling me that
it really makes my wife mad husband
yes stop doing that I I do have a wife
now and she doesn't like it but that's
the fun of it a lot of the supporting
cast like tigresa and some of these
other people were with merlin when he
was head of the League of Assassins then
they broke off so it also gives you an
idea for what Merlin was doing last
season when he wasn't around on screen
so it's really cool backstory to give
him but I feel like they should have
teased that out in previous season or
even when he was on legends of tomorrow
the problem with that is that the
writers of that TV show probably didn't
know what the arrow people planned for
in the arrow people probably didn't even
know how they were gonna ride him off
the show they could have made that
character so much more interesting like
season 1 Merlin is probably peak Merlin
so let me know in the comments what's
your favorite Thea moment from arrow so
far and what's your favorite Merlin
moment so far I still love that early
storyline where Oliver first discovers
that Merlin is the dark Archer and they
just throw down with each other in that
office one of the best fights that
they've ever done on the TV show period
and then the whole resurrection of
Thea's storyline was a really awesome
premise but I don't like what they did
with it after the fact so there was a
bunch of other stuff happening in the
episode you still have the running
storyline with them trying to route out
all the corrupt people in the police
department they finally find out that
the police captain is corrupt by the end
of the episode they bring back vertigo
which is a deep cut from season 1 and
season 2 but the other really big news
that they just announced
is that caity lotz is actually going to
be in the arrow finale so they're gonna
do like their birds-of-prey episode
because you have black siren which is
kind of a version of Black Canary dark
twists on the character from earth to
the current Black Canary right now and
then the former Black Canary I know they
called her the canary but let's not
split hairs
she was effectively the show's first
version of Black Canary and still I
think the best version of Black Canary
sorry she's bleeding it's not deep good
I can't take any more scars
speaking of Lord around yeah I a deed a
patek a province Afghanistan good I I
know my wounds grenade Algiers
I've never been hit by a grenade all
those scars you know be hit by a grenade
arrow knife knife lot of bullets no
grenades I got myself a new bullet 9
millimeter right then 38 almost i swords
in a spear I think one of the biggest
mistakes that arrow producers made in
previous seasons was in not sort of
retooling the makeup of their show
turning her into a main cast member
it is retooling their original plans for
how the series would pan out because
there are a lot of awesome characters in
the arrowverse but caity lotz is one of
those people that's worth like three
characters so whatever they've been
listening to your fan mail they're
bringing her back to arrow I've been
asking for a birds-of-prey episode for a
long time now but I think the real
question we're all asking now though is
is it now that original cast members are
starting to leave the show does this
mean that arrow really will end after
its 7th season because the thing about
TV is that it's designed to make money
if it's still making money they'll keep
making it Stephen Amell is only signed
along with most of the main cast through
season 7 so if they do decide to do a
season 8 then they'll have to resize him
to a new contract he'll get a big bump
in pay so it'll cost way more money so
there's all kinds of factors that go
into arrow going beyond seven seasons
but I think it's a little early to talk
about that but let me know in the
comments do you actually think that
arrow goes past seven seasons but I'm
working on a video for that leaked
Deadpool footage from the TV show that
got canceled remember how Ryan Reynolds
leaked the test footage back at Comic
Con a couple years ago somebody just did
the same thing for the Deadpool TV
series so we'll do a video for that then
I'll do some new Dragonball but leave
all your video requests in the comments
below click here for brand new infinity
war and click here for brand new flash
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome
tonight